raquel garrido est ce que vous êtes sur
un niveau totalement totalement
ah oui et pas que le 7 janvier il ya une
confiance qui le sont le 7 janvier puis
lui tu sais je suis toujours charlie je
serai toujours charlie je pense que la
liberté sud si on ne s'en sert pas
comment vous expliquez que 38% des
français qu'ils ne soient plus charnues
ben je peux vous dire que je pense que
c'est une sorte de pudibonderie qui
c'est qui s'est accrue dans la société
et une sorte d'intégration du fait que
quelque part il ya un risque à critiquer
les religions moi je le vois même avec
me ma fille et ma deuxième fille inès
qu'à 17 ans elle aime pas trop les
vannes sur la religion elle pourtant
c'est pas ça veut dire c'est pas dans sa
culture l appareil est pas fan du tout
des vannes sur la religion
donc voilà je trouve que la société
arrière du ton globalement a reculé dans
la tolérance qu'elle a vis-à-vis de
cette tradition de il faudrait tous la
même sensibilité cd qu'on soit tous
gérés en phase et il a mérité l'argent
mais on peut trouver nous passâmes a
fait ça d'ailleurs je n'ai je tu t'es
moi de dire même si tu l'a pas dit on
n'est pas charlie parce que comme on
dire interdire à quelqu'un de se dire je
fais de dire je ne suis pas charlie
charlie être charlie c'est accepter que
quelqu'un puisse dire je suis pas jaloux
cheryl barker être jaloux c'est une
injure faite à celle de la liberté
d'expression
mais au delà de la liberté d'expression
qui je crois vraiment et consensuelle 1
me semble que c'est pas tellement sur ce
point là que les uns et les autres on va
avoir des des contradictions
là ce qui est un petit peu plus tôt çi
c'est l'intensité de loup et même on va
dire de la critique acerbe contre le
fait religieux contre le fait de penser
qu'il ya des divinités qui régit ce
qu'ils ont et ça c'est quelque chose qui
est pas comment dire simple parce que
les les gens qui croient pas ils sont où
ils existent ils sont nombreux et vont à
l'acte la liberté conscience ailleurs
viala divisionnaire électif mais
attention dans plein pays du monde moi
je viens d'amérique latine en amérique
latine la laïcité ça n'existe même pas
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de religion ça
n'existe pas on n'est pas pratiquants à
la limite même et pas croire en dieu
sait que watts à bursa n'existe pas donc
c'est des choses en france qui ont été
cultivés qui ont été culture goût alors
voilà voilà voilà exactement et donc moi
je trouve ça précieux au ski en france
cette cette liberté là bien sûr je
trouve que c'est important mais voilà
c'est la raison des routes au loin pour
lesquelles je suis charlie